the eye of a storm  debris swirling caught on camera and  posted online  the violent weather swept parts of  western and central germany and  generated three tornadoes this one  touching down and lipstick in the  northwest  the storm cell also brought rain hail  and strong gusts of wind  the basements of hundreds of homes were  flooded and leftover debris stopped many  people from leaving  this church lost its steeple its  remnants now blocking the junction of a  road  this storm was part of a weather system  that produced severe weather on thursday  and friday  it disrupted traffic and uprooted trees  that toppled onto rail tracks and roads  the regional fire service said all  available rescuers were deployed  germany usually experiences several  tornadoes a year as colder air from the  north clashes with warmer air from the  south  lea harding al jazeera